and this is what I'm talking about when I'm talking about fat fashion
and the lack of accessibility
I get invited to a party
a nice party on Monday
it's Friday I have looked at literally every option
I called in the fat cavalry
I checked in with my friends
I look at the clothes that I have literally no option
currently heading to Staten Island to visit my family
and I'm gonna see now if there's anything that I can use that like
I forgot that I own
considering getting something tailored
trying to find out what I can get shipped
but it's Friday
and like yes
this would be like a kind of situation for anybody trying to find an outfit
but when I say there are no options
I'm not exaggerating
I'm gonna go visit my family
we're gonna have a car
but there's nowhere to even drive to
to try and find a place where I can shop in person
because nowhere has my size
look at the torrid in Staten Island
maybe plus Brooklyn
which is a vintage store that sells plus sizes
but those are literally
literally my only options
it's just frustrating how difficult this entire endeavor is because like
I'm so excited to do this with my friend
like hang out
we have a great time regardless
but it's just so frustrating cause my friends like
oh let's go shopping here
let's look at this
da da da
and I'm like yes
like awesome
but still it's like
I can't do that
I have to figure out my shit on my own
and they're like my
my friends are like oh
maybe I'll reach out to this person and like
maybe they'll dress me like whatever
and I'm like I can't wait to see the outfit
but at the same time again
it's just so frustrating how difficult it is to find clothing in our size
literally the most evil position that a fat person can be in
and it's just like
I just wish we would have a little bit more options
like a couple more places
like if there was a handful
a handful there's two
and it's not even two within the city
it's two within a two hour trip of me
like I'm gonna look good regardless
but god it's fucking annoying